so let's look at two examples of using
the well ordering principle one of them
is pretty obvious and the other one is
not hard but a little bit more
interesting so what we're going to prove
is that every integer greater than 1 is
a product of primes so remember a prime
is an integer greater than 1 that is
only divisible by itself and the number
1 it can't be expressed as the product
of other numbers greater than 1 so the
way we're going to prove this is by
contradiction
and we're going to begin by assuming
suppose that there were some numbers
that were non products of primes
ok that is to say the set of non
products is non-empty so applying the
least the well ordering principle to
this non empty set of non products
there's got to be at least one so M is a
number greater than 1 that is not a
product of primes now by convention if M
itself was a prime is considered to be a
product of one prime so we know that M
is not a prime
now look em is not a prime or if it was
a prime it would be a product of just
itself so that means that it must be a
product of two numbers Coulomb J and K
where J and K are greater than one and
less than M that's what it means to be a
non-prime it's a product of J and K well
j and k are less than m so that means
that they must be prime products because
they're less than m and greater than 1
and m is the smallest such number that's
not a product of primes so we can assume
that J is equal to some product of prime
say P 1 through P 94 and K is some other
product of primes q1 through q4
so you can see where this is going
now what we have is that M which is JK
is simply the product of those P is
followed by the product of those Q's M
is in fact a prime product which is a
contradiction so what did we assume that
led to the contradiction we assume that
there was some counter examples and
there must not be any and no counter
examples means that in fact every single
integer greater than 1 is indeed a
product of primes as
let's start looking at a slightly more
interesting example using the
well-ordered principle two reasoning
about postage so suppose that we have a
bunch of five cent stamps and three cent
stamps and what I want to analyze is
what amounts of postage can you make out
of five cent stamps in three cent stamps
so I'm going to introduce a technical
definition for convenience let's say
that a number n is postal if I can make
n plus eight cents postage from three
and five cent stamps okay so this is
what I'm gonna prove I claim that every
number is postal in other words I can
make every amount of postage from eight
cents up okay I'm gonna prove this by
applying the well ordering principle and
as usual with well ordering principles
will begin by supposing that there was a
number that wasn't postal that would be
a counter example so if there's any
number that's not postal then there's a
least one em by the well ordering
principle because the set of Cather
examples is non-empty if some number is
not postal so there's at least one so
what we know in other words is that this
least m that's not postal has the
property it's not postal and any number
less than it is postal
what we can figure out about em first of
all em is not zero zero was postal
because zero plus eight cents can be
made with a 3-cent stamp and a five cent
stamp M is not zero because M is
supposed to be not postal as a matter of
fact by the same reasoning M is not one
because you can make one plus eight
cents with three threes and M is not 2
because you can make two plus eight
cents 10 cents using two fives so we've
just figured out that this least counter
example has to be greater than or equal
to three because 0 1 & 2 are not counter
examples so we've got that M is greater
than equal to 3 the least non-postal
number so if I look at M minus 3 that
means it's a number that's greater equal
to 0 and it's less than M so it's postal
because M is the least non-postal one
alright so in other words I can make out
of 3 & 5 cent stamps I can make em minus
3 plus 8 cents but look if I can make M
minus 3 plus 8 cents then obviously M is
postal also because I just add 3 cents
to that M minus 3 number and I wind up
with M plus 8 cents which says that M is
postponed as a contradiction so assuming
that there was a least non-postal number
I reach a contradiction and therefore
there is no non-postal number every
number is postal 0 Plus 8 is postal 1
plus 8 is postal 2 plus 8 is postal
every number greater than or equal to 8
cents can be made out of 3 & 5 cent
stamps